his name was Geralt of Rivia he was a
Witcher a professional monster slayer
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we found out
all kinds of stuff about The Witcher
series when it's gonna drop how many
episodes that are gonna be so there's
just gonna be a breakdown of what's
going on Longclaw is gonna have to stand
in for his swords at the moment I need
to get some replicas but he has two
swords one of them is named sahil but
one of them silver one of them steel
there was a Netflix event in Rome
recently where they talked about the
series everyone went crazy so it sounds
like the showrunner was clear to talk
about details of how the show would be
structured when the episodes would drop
they haven't announced any casting yet
but if you remember when they were
ramping up for Game of Thrones it's kind
of like that
so hopefully they don't wind up like
Game of Thrones is now where they don't
release any information and none of the
stars are on social media posting about
it so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get the
videos obviously I'll be doing episodes
for this when it gets here but it's
gonna be a while so first big thing she
said that the series probably wouldn't
premiere till 2020 which makes sense
because they haven't cast it yet they
haven't hired any of the key people in
any of the departments that are actually
gonna be shooting it she of course said
that they'd be shooting it in Eastern
Europe just to maintain the look and
feel of the series I think everyone kind
of assumed that that was gonna happen so
if you are a production person and you
live in Eastern Europe you might have a
shot at working on this series because
they're staffing up really soon but the
reason why it's probably not gonna drop
till 2020 is because even if they're
able to cast the show and start shooting
it by the end of this year they have to
finish all the episodes before they can
premiere it and it usually takes some
about six months to promote a show
Netflix isn't really great at promoting
their shows like they'll drop a couple
trailers they might do a bunch of
interviews stranger things season two is
a good example of a really big show of
theirs that they put a lot of money
behind in marketing hopefully they'll do
the same thing for The Witcher because I
do think that they want this to be their
big game of Thrones show they have a
couple series that seem like they're
really big but the only ones that they
make a lot of noise about year to year
are the Marvel Netflix series and
because of the Disney streaming service
I think that Netflix wants to get its
hands on some really good original IP
that it can control not something that's
co-owned by Disney she confirmed that it
would probably be 8 episodes for the
first season but like a lot of Netflix
series they might expand that to 10 or
13 depending on
how it does the reason why it's only 8
is mostly for budgetary reasons in for
pacing reasons one of the big problems
that Netflix has with its Marvel shows
is that they're all 13 episodes but they
feel like there's six episodes of story
so people are just like oh god this is a
slog to get through this she did say the
scripts still need to polish but when
someone suggested or said that she had
claimed that it was going to be sword of
Destiny in last wish - the short stories
that take place before sort of like the
main body of the novels she was like I
don't think that I've said that so she
didn't confirm exactly what the story
would be but if you played the game then
you know that the game is basically a
continuation of the books story in the
show is probably going to be doing the
books so I would expect maybe some minor
edits but for the most part you've read
the novels that's basically what they're
going to be doing for the TV show so
it's not like it's gonna be a sequel to
the games or anything like that like
they're not gonna keep moving forward in
the timeline if you haven't read the
books last wish and sword of Destiny or
like a collection of short stories last
wish is the first one he sort of sits in
a church and recounts previous
adventures that he's been on through a
series of what becomes those short
stories so it starts with voice of
reason The Witcher grain of truth the
lesser evil a question of price the edge
of the world
the last wish sword of Destiny is the
second book of short stories but it was
published first but it takes place after
the events of last wish so if you want
to read things chronologically he reads
sword of Destiny second but it just
depends on how you like to experience
the story if you're not familiar with
the series at all or you just started
playing the game's Geralt is basically a
monster hunter that goes from town to
town in exchange for payment like it's
his profession to lift the curse that
held a monarchs daughter it was enough
to spend the night with the princess
dusk till dawn
if only she were not a deadly beast a
Striga
the traitor responsible for the curse
became the bait so I think that's also
one of the reasons why it's gonna take
till 2020 to get the series here because
it's not just like Game of Thrones where
you're trying to just do dragons or just
do dire wolves or minor special effects
like that they're doing all manner of
supernatural creatures so it's just a
lot more diverse in the sizes and types
of monsters that he fights like he could
fight really big dragons he could fight
really small undead people he could
fight spirits pretty much anything you
could imagine
[Applause]
dwarves elves all manner of fantasy
creature exists within the world so I
think it's gonna be pretty exciting if
you're a big fan of fantasy series but
obviously the thing to do until the
series gets here is just play the games
even though the game studio has said
that they don't plan on making a witcher
4 they did say that they're adding
Geralt to Soul Calibur 6 this year so
that's like the big place that the
character is going to be showing up but
I wouldn't be surprised if the Netflix
series does well if Netflix wants to
throw some money behind some game
development but they're not in the
business of making video games so I
wouldn't hold my breath for that but
people always do joke about Netflix as
deep unlimited pockets my hope is is
that even if they don't spin off a whole
bunch of other IP for their Netflix
series that they at least greenlight a
season 2 for more episodes maybe 13
I've never seen an epic series with this
scope and budget as big as what this
looks like it's going to be do more than
13 episodes so that's just like where my
expectations are for potential future
seasons but like if you've seen the
anime in the animated series that
Netflix has been doing recent like
Castlevania is a really solid series
they only did it four episodes just
because they didn't know if it'd be
successful and it's really expensive to
do stuff like that so they kind of test
it out like here you know as a really
small story that was originally gonna be
a movie so we're just gonna break it
into four parts people loved it so much
they came back for season two with eight
episodes so speaking of which there were
actually will be a cast
vania season 2 trailer sometime late in
May that's I think when the season 1
trailer dropped so I am expecting season
2 that to drop sometime in July I
wouldn't be surprised if when witcher
does drop during 2020 they do try to
drop it sometimes spring or summer
netflix has a lot more competition
during the traditional TV watching
season but with a series as big as this
i don't think that'll be as much of an
issue in because the game of thrones
main series will have already ended and
they might not have the Lord of the
Rings series ready to go in the game of
Thrones prequel series may not have
premiered yet this looks like it won't
have as much competition as it would
normally have so hopefully it'll get a
little more attention but let me know in
the comments what kind of bonus videos
you want me to do until they premiere
because if they haven't even hire the
people to actually shoot the series or
even cast the actors it's gonna be a
long time before we see a trailer so
once we learn a little bit more about
what their start date is gonna be and
once they start announcing who some of
their cast members are I'll do another
video but just leave all your requests
in the comments below what's gonna
happen this weekend though is that
Westworld season 2 is going to premiere
I'll be doing videos for that Sunday
nights just like I normally would if
you've found my channel since season 1
premiere it's been forever since season
1 so no worries
but click here for new Game of Thrones
in the meantime and click here for that
last big Westworld trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]